[Musik]
jedoch ist nicht das organ dürfen nur so
spaziert er die religion auf denen
miteinander so viel spaß wie ferien oder
funktioniert also von mir seine liebe
boomt und wenn möglich dass wir
interlaken boomt die besucher kommen aus
aller welt
carlén tourismusort zu viele gäste haben
oder sind es die falschen mit diesen
fragen bin ich ins berner oberland
gefahren
[Musik]
die einheimischen untersicht zu finden
ist nicht mehr so einfach
ich versuche es bei den proben der
tellspiele die hier eine über 100 jahre
alte tradition haben die meisten
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler sind
aus der region und viele im tourismus
tätig man sei sich der zentralen
bedeutung des tourismus durchaus bewusst
sagt theaterleiter und hersteller pascal
minder aus einer historischen
perspektive könne man den derzeitigen
boden aber auch kritisch beobachten
[Gelächter]
regiert decken aus damaliger zeit
umsetzen ließe wäre das standhaft und
eine gute musik ist dass die heimischen
wälder moore gelungen diese zu ende
macht kommen
bei den freilichtspielen sind die
meisten besucher schweizer ausländische
touristen sind hier selten zu gast
aber die malta kommen die einheimischen
laiendarsteller fast täglich mit den
vielen internationalen besuchen in
kontakt
der analytiker
das wird nicht mehr ab und das geht so
die konflikte häufig ist es dass man die
anwender dass man jedes jahr acht darauf
dass man sagt dass man sie kennt und
natürlich den letzten jahres ist sehr
viel möglich
duh hat sich vielleicht winter
tatsächlich war aber das ist mir bis vom
gefühl oder das war mein alltag konkret
wird es natürlich je nach tennis also
freue
das ist sicher bis wo man sich nicht so
gar nicht
und was noch ja sie durch zufällig
hinterfragen wo das zum beispiel gut
geht gar nicht was die toilette hier
wirkte aber ruft pass nur genau sie den
satz passt einfach nicht okay
[Applaus]
na ja so ganz europäisch gespielt so ich
setzte david die hier jetzt mal ob sie
vom terror der tourismus wenn das
miteinander verglichen
also wo interlaken sticht sind die große
rote oder ist das langsam immer mehr und
setzte sie mit der trend aus ja wieso
also was ist nicht schön
also wir die kennen es eigentlich die
ganze geschafft sie den optimismus im
sterben
dieses spiel tomb raider seiten der
gewerkschaft
wie schafft man es nach frischem blut
die großstädte was aber sie ganz schlimm
finde ich dass die heimischen einfach
einmal irgendwie noch neue regelung soll
und darum dass ich das wäre dank einer
der hotels am ausländer vermittelt ist
jürg zumkehr von der firma hotel
vorstellen
davor hat sich positiv sitze die
verdammen hotel da derzeit die sitze
gewonnen
sie berät oder lasst uns doch günstig es
gern
ich habe einfluss konstruktiv
ausländische anfang auch das hotel krebs
ging vor jahren an ausländer wie jedes
zweite verkaufte hotel in letzter zeit
ein ehepaar aus südkorea hat es gekauft
und danach für sieben millionen franken
renoviert
es laufe gut sagt zumkehr macht damit
realisierte 14 renoviert im stil wie
jetzt dann jetzt also inklusive
privatzimmer wenn hier sage das rentiert
wieso hat schwitzt nicht mehr butter
spitze sie weniger risiko und sehr oft
fällt nötige kapital und sehr oft die
banken nicht bereit über den tragweite
finanzieren
wir sind damals die reaktion ex evans
chris kotowski dann koreaner und stimme
in die heimische ja wo sitzt das bloß
fertig sie ja die frage mit dem anbieter
stellt denia bringen die schweizer
kunden von fotolia spitze ist realität
ich habe andere sehr oft pdf schon
wieder untergebracht
hierzu jetzt sozusagen sieht verbindung
von alt und neu das thema lasse
das ist ein früheres ob sie was wir vor
der gäcd sehr geschätzt und vom
denkmalschutz haben das wissen für
pflichten der muckibude eigentlich los
und dann hört dann ist ihr freund aber
gemacht wenn man das geister studie
abzuges stunde ist der picanto wir immer
des mieters unikat in einem hotel
der winterberger stehen das ist bisher
sound nix und dein büro von der
denkmalpflege harmlos asi pt.ii trinke
berge stehen lassen da die koreaner
gesetz ein stinker berges stehen soll
oder txt wenn das delikt wurde
denkmalpflege wie der teufel das
akzeptieren aber sind das mit meiner
tour aufeinander prallten
immer wenn es zu der klaren und der
gründer der blüten
viele ausländische hotelbesitzer
scheuten die öffentlichkeit meint
zumkehr
er hatte mehrere angefragt aber niemand
wollte vor die kamera
[Musik]
da ist jetzt auf der bank wie ich jetzt
leider wurde sie als vp politikerin geht
es am svp und der ausverkauf der heimat
regt sich sehen und ja das verdreht sich
sehr gut
ich stelle einfach fest wenn es darum
geht um große objekt wie sie einfach
spitze nicht darum hat das gut vertreten
war die in der kritik weil wir sie sagt
ja da war die lücke westhausen schuldig
was sagen sie ja gesagt der wurst auch
sie und ich sage ja was wettert er
das hotel braucht da steigt oder dass
das kauft wird 7 millionen investiert
wird und danach wieder touristen und
einheimische aus gast bot er als
hotelgast zurückgestellt also der
isländer kommen wenn er gaal bringt der
russland russland
doch wo andere wohnung aufkommen schweiz
kann man aber damit nicht darüber reden
ganz aktuell ist der verkauf des
traditionsreichen hotel sonne in matten
bei interlaken im frühling ging es an
käufer aus indien
zum bedauern des gemeinderates die
ausländischen käufer erhielten damit
auch die wird die rechte fürs eishockey
stadion und führt die teil festspiele
wie es bei den testspielen nun mit der
verpflegung weitergeht ist ungewiss aber
immer so sein muss mit einer karte mit
anna lüth mutter mit einer kamera was
wir schon haben wir musik ist von rasur
im eigenes muster fremder zürcher jetzt
kurse
die fremde garmisch almeida nordhoff die
hämische zu aber das gilt umgekehrt
nicht mehr dort möglichkeit auf die
fremde zu uns kommen also zuversichtlich
darf nur der klassik findet
in interlaken sind in den letzten jahren
die immobilien preise
überdurchschnittlich gestiegen
zudem werden inzwischen hunderte von
wohnungen über die online plattform
airbnb vermietet
die gemeinde war gezwungen hier klare
regeln zu schaffen
für ärger sorgt der verkehr massen von
reisecars zu jeder tageszeit
zudem kommen viele gäste mit mietautos
obwohl sie überfordert sind mit den
hiesigen verkehrsregeln
[Musik]
für die arabischen gäste gibt es
übrigens inzwischen ein erkläre video
wie man sich in interlaken verhalten in
solchen modell unter anderem bei rot
anhalten
gute portion
die touristik roth sagen es sei
nachvollziehbar dass im sommer manche
einheimische einen gewissen dichte
stress verspüren aber von problemen wie
in venedig oder barcelonas einmal noch
weit entfernt
den so genannten over to reason gebe es
nicht
ich finde sie überstrapaziert thema was
außerhalb foto wirklich top top saison
ist aber ich sage juli und august
der dax musste aber immer genug
möglichkeiten sie heimischen oder apps
alten personen mit einem us etat der hot
spots sowie den hörer weg zum beispiel
wo trotzdem wunderschön ist zum
flanieren
aber das ist ob sie jetzt thema in den
anderen dem winterpalast im winter
hämmerli hotel ausweichen tut auch sie
annemarie meter teamleiterin in einem
altersheim
wenn sie an ihrem freien tag wochen geht
dann schnellstmöglich weg von
überlaufenen zentrum
da muss ich aufpassen und luca und
backofen sie haben wir hofften das ist
ruhiger wenn man nicht sofort neue jahr
ist noch kein meter mit dem zur hatte
mit dem hengst sonntag und spazierte in
aktion gesehen und die humanmedizin
eingesetzt ausgelöscht wurde den höheweg
ist tatsächlich seit jahren in touristen
hand
[Musik]
sehen sie überall inder wir haben eine
gruppe von 600 leuten mitgebracht
mancher einheimische sorgen es gebe
inzwischen zu viele gäste aber das ist
doch wichtig für die einnahme das geld
der feriengäste ist doch wertvoll
überall
wir werden in indien sehr froh darüber
wir werden das bei uns auch schaffen
sind die einheimischen nett zu ihnen
[Musik]
einheimischen wir haben keine
möglichkeit einheimische zu treffen sind
sie ein ja schon manche leute hier sagen
es gebe zu viele touristen es kommt
drauf an wo in luzern ja da sind zu
viele touristen aber wenn du nach
appenzell fährst du sei nach pontresina
dort triffst du die echten schweizer und
die sind zone und verändert sich eher
zum nachteil sind also viele leute
einfach zu viel jetzt und doch das
geschäft läuft von den unternehmen hört
man fast keine klagen im gegenteil
asiaten und araber geben mehr geld aus
als europäer
[Musik]
momente textil für hof also zwischen t
shirt ist im moment ein nachbar jahr
begrenzt filmzitat wo man schon gut ja
da das projektdesign wir machen ja ich
bin ich richtig 10.28 uhr geht sie
magnetisch und afrika 70 jahre in der
schweiz ag sowie herr hofer als genesis
produkten also wieder zufrieden es ist
ja an die 90 der einheimischen arbeiten
in der gemeinde interlaken im
dienstleistungssektor
der souvenirladen betreiber kann das
klagen nicht nachvollziehen
die hämischen nicht ganz vom patienten
mit lokal und je vom tourismus was ist
für die touristenflieger das städtli
dort und das müssen wir klar hier brütet
die tische und england finden den mix
ist das schönste
das liegt auch hier war das macht
gewaltig ich möchte ja ich war hier auch
mit denen sie hier laufe israel ja warum
für sie jetzt genannt religion auf denen
die eu hat viel spaß ferien oder
funktioniert also von mir seine liebe
liebe
mixa werden möglich dass wir aber sind
nicht alle so doof dass sich lediglich
ist politische problem ja das stimmt ja
wo ich zum teil hinter eine fusion oder
ja die auch das paket befinden also
dass die technik nur die lücken haben
[Musik]
unsere letzte station war der kohlen
der hausberg von interlaken
im volksmund inzwischen arlberg genannt
[Musik]
mai ruder und ihr mann so lehmann aus
saudi arabien sind schon zum zweiten mal
in der schweiz
und sie bleiben gleich zwei wochen
[Musik]
die
ich habe auf snap chat ein foto
veröffentlicht und geschrieben wir sind
im paradies das hier ist doch das
paradies der ganzen welt jede frau ist
verhüllt gibt das problem
nein überhaupt nicht alle grüßen uns
niemand fragt was das soll
als ihm freundliche leute den weg ins
vermeintliche paradies sollen in zukunft
noch viel mehr menschen finden
wer jetzt schon von dichte stress
spricht muss sich auf etwas gefasst
machen
der chef des hardter coolen erwartet
noch viel mehr touristen
also wir sagen sie auch ganz ganz normal
fan von damals überhaupt fußweg heute
nachbar jahr
das ist dass er aber die jungfraubahn
und so weiter
das meldet das mit erfolg über
militärherrscher instrument aber langsam
versandt er hat für das er als 55 sags
ja dafür fiel am ende das definition
frau joop fischt der havel müssten auch
in von uns resümierte dass du überhaupt
glück für ganz harte brocken auf das
handy oder toter fische landen eines
neuen fachgebiet drogen bis ich am
anfang ist
[Musik]